du
[Musique]
comment ça va très bien on sera tous les
soirs et quand maxime gagner pour nous
d'aller les scoops du paf les infos du
pape et mon maxime tu seras tous les
sens d'exit par rapport à un disque ou
pau une des images que tu nous dois
absolument boys à d'accord alors à votre
avis est-ce que vous avez une idée sur
le couple comme ça surtout déguisés ont
un mec en fait qui a voulu faire une
parodie du clip de m pokora mais c'est
loupé totalement elle veut que ce soit
enfin tout à l'heure vous avez rencontré
une star une star américaine elle a 27
ans de carrière 68 films et séries à son
actif deux stars 2 novembre sarah
l'occasion la sortie d'un film qui va
faire événement
oui on peut le dire bassila de base si
monsieur hanouna a rencontré ce midi on
a tourné un sketch avec will smith et
martin
c'est vrai qu'on a tourné un sketch que
je vous diffuserez demain si chine c'est
vraiment et ils ont joué le jeu à fond
voilà d'où me libre et will smith ont
été exceptionnels au rang de ceux ci et
on a tourné un sketch on a fait ça dans
un très grand hôtel au ritz au bar du
ritz et vous verrez le sketch demain et
nous parlons de bad boys voilà voilà
elle fuit sa exceptionnel et martin
lawrence aussi d amour et je vous le dis
c'est vraiment des professionnels
on a tourné le sketch avait déjà révisé
avant ils sont arrivés ils n'ont fait
qu'une prise toujours serré et on les
croyait en anglais le sketch non on a
fait un truc énorme c'est qu'il avait
des oreillettes de quoi je parle en
français ok et eux me comprenez en
anglais et il parlait en anglais et moi
je fais des gens je les comprenais et
les acp sera demain vers et franchement
avait un grand grand moment j'adore
martin lawrence et will smith je suis
fan absolu depuis des années et il a la
classe ça a été un hameau on s'est très
bien entendu nous allons ramener des
huit séquences appel à nous pour
pratiquer un peu bas du dos
c'est la première info et ne sera donc
de maintenir et s'éviter toutes les
vidéos avec le sky sonates et qualité
évidemment pas les deuxièmes deuxième
info info on est en 2020 évidemment tout
le monde le sait et il ya des émissions
qui sont extrêmement attendu en gros on
sait que la première
bien sûr de voice and the voice est de
retour
[Rires]
r
et
tu de base est que si l'on changeait
tous les coachs on les connait isabelle
tu le connais par coeur la fabian de
marc lavoine pascal obispo ce sont des
nouveaux coaches dessus voilà et les
règles ont été simplifiés puisque la
mécanique est beaucoup plus fluide
puisque les audiences peu en fait c'est
donc the voice est de retour qu'en 2 le
18 la terminer le volet des candidats
terminé la zone rouge back to basics
elle annonce vouloir la bande-annonce en
remercie mais on est dans le bon on
savait exactement où je suis il ya kho
lanta aussi car l'antenne retour ça
s'appelait l'île des héros c'est la 21e
saison bientôt sur tf1
nouveauté aussi consistante avec des
anciens qui vont venir aider les
anonymes de cette année c'est que
plusieurs noms étaient sûrs à moussa
sarah jessica voulait dormir tranquille
calme-toi n'a pas d'autre chose
calme-toi lille généralement on devait
juste à voir les images derrière ce qui
a été diffusé mais voilà que vous avez
bien beau si jamais et enfin il ya
julien courbet est de retour enfin être
à la tête d'une nouvelle émission qui va
s'appeler qui veut être mon associé
adaptation d'un format japonais à succès
le concept est simple vous avez ces
investisseurs qui vont investir sur des
projets d'entrepreneurs c'est une super
idée et ça arrive la main des prochains
allez une autre info c'est les
personnalités les plus citées dans la
presse en 2019
vous avez le classement le classement
alors donc les personnalités qui ont été
le plus mentionné manche et dans
l'approximation
alors on va commencer par les politiques
en politique et qui était le plus cité
enfin m x consécutif cette année
en sport tas maps api web apps est très
très bien talonné par neymar et enfin
aux médias celui qu'on appelle ici
l'animal
[Musique]
enfin
émile citations en 2019
rien que ça là vous ont je pense que
vous allez en avoir beaucoup plus après
votre corps vous voyez bon bac si ce
matin j'ai lu mon post est radieux
qu'est ce que je vois je vois chez les
foules ce que tu vois la radio oui et ce
matin et je me casse cou faite à la
radio sur skyrock d'accord oui j'étais
chioui difool m'a appelé ce matin je
voudrais le remercier
difool sur skyrock voilà merci à eux
puisque difool a décerné le prix de
l'animateur de la décennie merci a dit
[Applaudissements]
je le pense vraiment que difool pour moi
et l'animateur dieu franchement radio 2
voilà pour moi c'est le meilleur de tous
les tâches et ce qui a largement et ce
qu'il a fait personne d'autre ne l'a
fait des foules
je suis fan de gaza un amour de mec et
il est dans son truc et c'est le
meilleur dans ce qu'il fait et je vous
le dis c'est vrai que c'est un passionné
et pour moi ça sera l'animateur voilà
pour moi à tina ses filiales et ses
trucs il fait le soir aussi
c'est incroyable ce qui fait alors tous
les soirs on reviendra sur quelque chose
d'aussi maxime c'est le tt ou le tt ou
petit jingle sonore ailleurs non mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous paraît que quelqu'un qu'on a perdus
de vue c'est qu'il s'agit de georges
alain jones candidats marquants de la
star ac' 2002 et 2002 c'est ça il est
sorti un album en 2005
mais depuis on se demande ce qui fait
c'est une vraie question c'est est-ce
qu'il a lancé une activité sportive
est-ce qu'il commente le sport à la
télévision où est ce qu'ils les coachs
sportifs dans une salle de sport non non
pas coach sportif aucun des trois alors
on se remémore déjà ce que fait déjà la
statue
[Musique]
c'est au fossat qui a pris il ya une
petite heure là il ya quelqu'un qui a
pris en plat on va perdre de la vitesse
peut-être permettra à marielle de ramaré
ce groupe c'est le cas d'ailleurs dans
la belle qui fait son effort
[Applaudissements]
sur l'équipe mais c'est ça la chaîne
équipes sont les sports de glisse et de
ski qui fait très mal parce qu'un lycéen
d'époux sympathique et aujourd'hui la 44
ans merci max in guinea vous revenez
demain c'est vous que ceux des non bien
sûr il sera là demain
[Applaudissements]